first of all how is it that you in
eighth grade yeah
how is it that Cher gets I mean Cher was
already a big star she was yeah so why
would she babysit you
um because it was the 70s I was friends
with sunny they were sharing the same
house even though they were separated
how does an eighth grader get to be
friends with Sonny uh who was a big star
in his own right my father's
ex-girlfriend became his girlfriend she
was my surrogate mother she's she kept
with me here she would come over and
what would you do for the night what
would be the in other words your dad
would be out
and your dad I guess was a ladies man a
drug taker all that kind of stuff so he
was out most nights yeah he was out
every night okay so so your dad at least
responsibly said hey let's have someone
watch the kid it was actually sunny and
this girl Connie
that were in charge of me for the
weekend and they went out and they said
sure could you watch Tony while we go
out
awesome yeah so what does Cher do when
she watches you I mean what do you do
you what do you play games do you we
talked you talked yeah she was cool I
mean she was a good hang how old was she
at the time
hard to say young 20s young yeah yeah
that was at the height of her beauty I
mean sweet and comforting and loving and
kind and smoke weed with her no would
have but didn't Sunny was very anti
there would be no weed in that house but
she was her own person at that point but
under that roof I don't think anyone was
smoking so when she came over would she
be wearing like hot outfits uh not hot
outfits but she was hot she was so not
hot that she was hot I mean you're
talking about one of the sexiest women
on the planet with the long legs and the
stomach and the whole attitude did you
know you want to be a singer at that
point
um it crossed my mind to be a singer
early on when I used to sing with my mom
listening to the AM radio and then I
gave that up for the idea of being an
actor and then I gave that up for the
idea of being a dope fiend and then I
came back to music it was almost like
you were destined to be famous or
something you're hanging out hanging out
with all the famous people uh that was
an early episode with hanging out with
famous people it didn't last
thank you